if I'm faced with a difficult Choice  such as should I marry this person  should I take this job should I buy this  house should I move the city should I go  in business with this person if you  cannot decide the answer is no and the  reason is because modern society is full  of options there are tons and tons of  options we live in a planet of seven  billion people we are connected to  everybody on the internet there's  hundreds of thousands of careers  available to you there are so many  choices you're biologically not built to  realize how many choices there are  because we evolved in tribes or tribes  of 150 people where if you pass that one  choice the second thing never comes  along also when you choose something it  takes you get locked in for a long time  if you start a business that's 10 years  so it's very very important that you  only say yes when you are pretty certain